uh i have actually this is a symbol i
have a little bit of trouble with
because i actually learned my astronomy
in america i was a phd student in
america and when i returned for a long
time i had to catch myself and not call
it z it was very strange because i
thought of the letter of zed but this
astronomical use of it i always thought
of a z rather than z anyway zed
is uh the symbol that astronomers use
for measuring redshift
so it was a big deal in astronomy i
guess at the beginning it started maybe
the beginning of the 20th century people
started looking at the light from
galaxies out there and this was actually
before they were known to be galaxies so
they were referred to as nebulae and
people started looking at the light from
these nebulae and found that they were
all redshifted which means in this
interpretation of you know where this
redshift comes from uh it means they're
all running away from us in fact even a
few objects that have blue shifts there
are things that are actually coming
towards us rather than going away from
us
one of the most interesting things that
actually has a blue shift is the
andromeda galaxy so the nearest big
galaxy to the milky way the andromeda
galaxy actually has a blue shift rather
than a redshift that means it's piling
towards the milky way and in fact in
about three or four billion years
there's going to be a big collision the
two galaxies are actually going to crash
into each other so by measuring the red
shifter in this case the blue shift you
can actually figure out when that
collision is going to happen what's
going to happen then what would that
look like and be like
from our perspective it's going to be
remarkably dull i have to say because
the thing you need to remember about
galaxies is they're almost entirely
empty space uh if you built a scale
model on the milky way and you made the
sun the size of a marble
um then the next nearest star so the
next nearest marble would be about 50
miles away
so basically galaxies really are mostly
empty space so if you take one load of
empty space and another load of empty
space and crash them into each other
they kind of just pass straight through
each other but what does happen of
course is that the pull of gravity of
the milky way on andromeda is going to
do terrible things to andromeda's kind
of arrangement and the same thing the
other way around do any stairs at all
hit each other very rarely if you do the
calculation to try and figure out
because they're mostly empty space they
mostly just miss each other and you'll
probably find in a conclusion like that
where you've got 10 billion stars on the
one hand and 10 billion stars on the
other hand
most maybe one of them will smash into
one other one so this is really not a
particularly common event
so it's very much akin to the kind of
doppler shift that everyone's familiar
with you know when a fire engine or a
police car goes past you and the siren
when the thing's coming towards you it's
slightly higher pitched
when the thing's going away from you the
pitch is slightly lower
and so the pitch changes depending on
the relative motion of these two things
so that's the doppler shift in sound
the same thing happens with light
the way i like to think about it is that
the universe has expanded so let's say
this is the universe at an early stage
maybe you know 10 billion years ago the
universe is continually expanding
remember and this is a
photon of light and that's the
wavelength of the photon so it's quite a
short wavelength so that means it's
quite a blue
photon of light but then the universe
expands as we know so let's expand the
universe
so the universe has expanded
significantly now and you can see the
wavelength of the light is significantly
longer and that means it's a redder
photon of light and that's what gives
you the redshift it's the stretching the
expansion of space-time as the universe
expands and so and that's one of the
neat things about the redshift by
measuring the redshift you not only know
the distance to this galaxy
using hubble's law which i know there's
another video about but you're also
looking very far back in time how did
you know they were redshifted how do you
know they just didn't happen to be more
red
so what you actually look at is you
don't look at just the general light
from things what you say is absolutely
true if you just see a bunch of red
light you say well maybe it's just
something that's red perfectly
reasonable to do but conveniently nature
kind of provides us with little markers
in in the spectrum
so that if you actually break the light
from a star up into its constituent
color so you put a prism or something
and break the light up you do indeed see
the colors of the rainbow but
superimposed on those colors of the
rainbow you see little dark lines and
each of those little dark lines is where
some element in the atmosphere of the
star is absorbing light at a very
specific wavelength
and so those provide nice little markers
that are a very specific wavelength so
we can do the experiment in the
laboratory and measure exactly the
wavelength they're supposed to be at and
then you go and make the same
measurement on a star and you find that
the little dark band due to absorption
is at a different wavelength so you can
see that it shifted towards the red so
this was from a long exposure on an
eight meter telescope in chile of one of
the faint galaxies in here i couldn't
tell you which one this is four thousand
angstroms that would look blue to your
eyes this is about seven or eight
thousand that would look red to your
eyes so this is an optical spectrum
um
but if you were closer to that galaxy
all of these lines would be shifted and
compressed over to the blue part of the
spectrum so this spectrum has stretched
basically as the universe has expanded
and then we measured it with our
telescope and we can determine how far
away it is so this is one of those
strange quantities that actually is
completely dimensionless as long as you
use the same units and do everything
consistently you end up with a
dimensionless number so the redshift is
actually defined such that if you have
one of these little dark absorption
lines say you have some hydrogen which
is absorbing at a particular wavelength
and you make that measurement in the
laboratory and you measure its
wavelength to be a certain number of
nanometers or angstroms or any unit you
want to measure it in and then you
measure the same thing in a star you
find it at a different wavelength so you
can measure the difference between those
numbers how much the wavelength has
changed and then you just divide that by
the wavelength you started with and
because you're dividing something in
nanometers or changing wavelength by
something else in nanometers and the
wavelength you started with you just end
up with a number and then it doesn't
matter whether you measure that
measurement in nanometers or furlongs or
whatever you want any unit of length you
like you'll always end up with the same
redshift i'm leading a project right now
where we can detect galaxies to redshift
of six which means the light stretched
by a factor of seven so what does that
mean in terms of the evolution of the
universe the light left those objects
over 12 billion years ago it's actually
it's mind-boggling when you think about
it i mean uh we're studying galaxies in
the universe's infancy we could produce
images of these galaxies study their
characteristics understand what elements
are present and we're seeing them before
the earth itself was even formed so this
is a project i was talking about we've
used many hundreds of nights of
telescope time
on a large telescope in hawaii the uk
infrared telescope to try and understand
galaxies in the very early universe so
we're using an infrared telescope
precisely because of this redshift
effect
if you study a galaxy in the very early
universe the light has been stretched by
such an extent
that the normal optical light that most
stars produce has been stretched into
the infrared
so up until fairly recently our
understanding of the very distant
universe was very biased because we used
optical telescopes all the optical
images we're all used to from hubble and
so on
when you're looking at the very distant
universe you only see a tiny fraction of
what's going on out there so what we're
seeing here is an image that we produce
by combining data from an optical
telescope in hawaii with an infrared
telescope so anything that looks blue
there you would be able to see with an
optical telescope or if you like you
know your eyes are sensitive to that
light
anything that looks red
for example these red blobs here
those will be completely invisible to an
optical telescope even to the hubble
space telescope
so as we pan across this image you see
that there are galaxies of all different
colours here's a very bright blue star
in our own galaxy it's so bright this
produces bleeding effect on the ccd
camera that's not real
it's just because it's so bright the
electrons spill over on the detector so
that's kind of a star in the foreground
that's ruined your photo absolutely yeah
they're a real pain they're getting away
what we're really interested in are the
blobs that you see behind so most of the
things you can see in this image
are
galaxies so here's a particularly
beautiful blue spiral a relatively
nearby spiral actually i'm not
particularly interested in that one what
i'm interested in are the fainter blobs
in the background those faint red dots
that you can maybe just see
invisible with an optical telescope we
now know from studying their redshift
that those are galaxies uh that was that
that
whose lights left the object
more than 10 11 12 billion years ago